effectivement les Américains attendent
des résultats de la contre-offensive et
forcément elles espèrent de bonnes
nouvelles bonjour Gulliver crack vous
êtes zakiev est-ce que volo des
meilleurs Zelenski va pouvoir les
rassurer
alors il va sans doute parler des
victoires récentes à côté de bakkmouth
ou de village ont été repris par l'armée
ukrainienne ces derniers jours notamment
Clichy 4 qui est un village situé
stratégiquement sur les lignes de chemin
de fer même si en réalité les Ukrainiens
à Clichy 4 font face à une
contre-offensive russe pour essayer de
reprendre ce village à leur tour c'est
souvent le cas il le faut souvent un
certain temps pour les Ukrainiens pour
consolider leurs gains et puis aussi la
direction de backmouth ce n'est pas
vraiment l'axe principal de cette
contre-offensive tout le monde attend
des résultats dans le sud dans la région
de zapporiza notamment et là il n'y a
pas d'avancer vraiment concrète à
annoncer ces derniers temps le progrès
de l'aveu de tout le monde et plus long
que prévu mais vous le dire delanski je
pense va essayer de pointer les succès
récents des Ukrainiens en termes de
frappe à longue distance notamment sur
les bases russes en Crimée assez
vastopol aussi dans la partie de la
région des aporisa occupé notamment
melithopole ou selon les Ukrainiens des
cibles importantes des Russes ont été
touchées et alors dans cette guerre
d'usure petit à petit les Ukrainiens
peuvent gagner l'avantage leur message
doit être que la contre-offensive va
certainement prendre plus de temps que
certains espérer mais ce n'est pas pour
cela que c'est impossible l'Ukraine peut
aussi parler de l'innovation ton matière
de drone de technologie militaire qui
peut être
utile pour le monde entier et puis bien
sûr c'est le message constant des
dirigeants Ukrainiens en ce moment
dans tous les instances internationaux
c'est de dire que cette guerre ne
concerne pas vraiment uniquement
l'Ukraine et bien l'ordre mondial et et
et le P à long terme dans le monde voilà
volodiaelens qui nouvelle fois qui va
devoir convaincre Gulliver il a aussi
besoin de se rassurer parce qu'en Europe
il y a l'un de ces soutiens
majeurs la Pologne qui lui fait faux bon
mais la Pologne va cesser de lui livrer
des armes à cause du contentieux
céréalier c'est un problème sérieux
oui assez sérieux certainement en termes
de la rhétorique polonaise il y a eu un
tournant anti-ukrainien assez marqué ces
derniers temps mais aujourd'hui au
ministère des Affaires étrangères en
Pologne ils se sont dit surpris par les
propos du Premier ministre hier qui
avait parlé a été arrêté ses livraisons
d'armes à l'Ukraine la Pologne du
clarifier en disant que les contrats
déjà signés seront remplies et puis à
l'origine de se disputent entre la
Pologne et l'ukrainien les exportations
agricoles de l'Ukraine vers la Pologne
qui ont augmenté de plus de 600% cette
année mettant en péril certains
agriculteurs polonais qui constituent un
électorat très important pour le parti
au pouvoir qui essaye de Briger un
troisième mandat le 15 octobre c'est
aussi cette considération électorale qui
se passe en Pologne en ce moment la
dernière nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est que
les ministres de l'agriculteur de
l'agriculture pardon ukrainien et
polonais ont convenu de se réunir pour
essayer de trouver une solution
se dispute donc il l'est à espérer que
le soutien de la Pologne à l'Ukraine ne
va pas vraiment cesser pour autant aussi
parce qu'il faut aussi prendre en
considération qu'une très très grande
partie de l'électorat en Pologne qui
pourrait aussi voter pour le parti au
pouvoir et très très hostile envers la
Russie et considère effectivement que
cette guerre de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine pourrait être une guerre
contre la Pologne si l'Ukraine ne tient
ne tient pas merci beaucoup Gulliver
Craig en direct de Kiev pour France 24